in the age of virtual political
conventions president trump
may accept the republican party
nomination at gettysburg
which is obviously the site of another
great oration by the first
republican president who like president
trump had to put down
violent insurrections led by democrats
and
who had to defend our liberties and to
defend our country
the symbolism so beautiful totally
fitting
cnn is furious and pam we've reported
that president trump is considering
delivering his gop
nomination acceptance speech from the
white house but amid some criticism
of that potential venue the president is
now floating another one this time
he's talking about the hallowed civil
war battlefield in gettysburg
pennsylvania
but that could be controversial too
particularly because this is a president
who has consistently
positioned himself as a defender of
confederate symbols
and monuments to confederate generals
pam yeah that's a fair point to make
that's not a fair point to make what is
a defender of confederate symbols
i guess it's just another way to say
he's a nazi he's a white supremacist
he's a terrible awful person you know
else was the defender of confederate
symbols
abraham lincoln the man who won the
civil war and freed all of the slaves
because he understood
we have to come together as a country we
have to recognize
what what history has done and how it's
shaped our country and how we need to
unite
all as americans with malice toward none
with charity
for all but the left doesn't want you to
understand history they want to
weaponize ignorance we'll fight back i'm
michael knowles this is the michael
knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment from yesterday on the youtubes
comes from muhammad farooq who says
as a muslim i say good for mr macarthur
defying a government that condones
peaceful protests aka
riots and essential services but doesn't
allow
the most essential of services this is
the point muhammad you hit the nail on
the head
in our material world where the left has
convinced us that
nothing exists except for flesh and
we're all just a bunch of meat puppets
kind of walking around
they think that the only essential
services are food and water but man does
not live
by bread and bread alone and our
civilization as it grew and flourished
always understood
that and now that we think we're just a
bunch of sort of
physical objects floating around in
space until we turn to
worm food now obviously that
civilization decays but we got to get it
back we have to
recognize that there is a spiritual
dimension of
life we need to protect our civilization
not just our civilization we got to
protect all that stuff too
fraudsters are trying to capitalize
these days by sending messages through
social media and emails
trying to get consumers to fall for a
scam that uses cash app it seems like
there's a new scam
every day this one has messages that
offer free money via the cash app
to help them through this difficult time
however the link in the message is
fraudulent it's malicious it could steal
money
and personal information there are a
zillion of these scams out there
very very important to protect your data
every day we put our information at risk
on the internet you can miss certain
identity threats
by just monitoring your credit well good
thing
there's lifelock these are the guys that
i trust lifelock
no one can prevent all identity theft or
monitor all transactions
at all businesses but lifelock can see
threats that you might miss
on your own join right now and you will
save
up to twenty five percent off your first
year go to lifelock dot com slash
knowledge
w l e s that is lifelock dot com slash
knowles
canada w l e s right now you can't do it
too soon
head on over so many threats out there
lifelock.com knows for 25 percent
off donald trump a defender of
confederate symbols what does that mean
if you don't want to tear down american
history if you don't want to tear down
our statues then you're a defender of
confederate symbols
he's a defender of the country he's a
defender of the country
against the actual violent marauders
walking around
running around peacefully rioting and
and harming people and breaking their
property and tearing down our country
but he's also defending them against the
ideological framework that is motivating
all of these protesters
and that you know you see that in the
media obviously we just saw that with
cnn you
see that all throughout the culture you
see that from hollywood
but where does it begin it begins with
the educational systems this is
something the left
has understood for at least 100 years
and the right hasn't caught up how
essential
the educational apparatus is
to the left's agenda and what they're
doing it's not that they're arming
the left you know future generations
with facts with information about our
history
what they're actually arming with them
with is ignorance
what they're teaching them is ignorance
there was this crazy study out of the
intercollegiate studies institute this
was now 13 years ago imagine how much
worse
it is now it looked at students at the
top colleges the all the elite colleges
it was a survey of american civics
politics history it showed that
graduating seniors
were more ignorant about their own
country than incoming freshmen
that was the product was that ignorance
and now the teachers are admitting it
it always comes back to education
there's a teacher i think when matt
walsh found this yesterday
it was kind of going around the internet
obviously this teacher has since deleted
the thread
matthew r k a founding teacher at the
science leadership academy
also known as sla not that sli very
different very bad sla
i guess with this teacher he tweets out
so this fall virtual class discussions
will have many potential spectators
parents siblings etc in the same room
we'll never be quite sure who's
overhearing the discourse
what does this do for our equity slash
inclusion work
how much of students depended on these
somewhat secure barriers of our physical
classrooms
to encourage vulnerability vulnerability
it's getting creepier by the second
right he's saying we don't want the
parents to hear the
the trash that we're teaching these kids
and we want them to be really vulnerable
away from their parents you want them to
be vulnerable
how many of us have installed some
version of what happens here stays here
to help us
okay even creepier while conversations
about race are in my wheelhouse
and remain a concern in this no-walls
environment i am most intrigued by the
damage that
helicopter snowplow parents can do in
honest conversations about gender
sexuality
red alert sirens going off this creepy
teacher
doesn't want the parents to hear what
he's saying to the kids especially on
issues of sex
and while conservative parents are my
chief concern i know that the damage can
come from the left too
if we are engaged in the messy work of
destabilizing a kid's
racism or homophobia or transphobia how
much do we want their classmates parents
piling on this guy is gonna manage to
get me
to vote for the covid lockdowns as you
know i've been pretty anti-locked down i
don't think there's any scientific
reason
to have the lockdowns anymore or to
force people to wear the masks all the
time we'll get into the science of that
later because
because it's a day that ends in y
there's more science coming out to
defend
our position on this and to oppose the
left position but now i'm sort of
rooting for the lockdowns because the
lockdowns are keeping the kids
out of these schools these these modern
day liberal madrasas
and out of the hands of these teachers
who are preying on kids and preying on
on separating kids from their parents
education is the issue here and the left
knows that
education it doesn't start when you
enter college it's much earlier than
that
it's why the left one it does want to
force kids into college so that they
have a little bit more time to be
indoctrinated in the state
ideology but it wants to start them
earlier too now public schools have
pre-k
when i was like i didn't go to pre-k
when i was a kid i started in
kindergarten and when my father was a
kid he didn't even go to kindergarten
but they keep adding on all these times
to keep you out away from your family
and spending more time in the public
government schools
to indoctrinate you in this ideology we
talked yesterday
about how you're always going to have
some kind of religion either it's going
to be a traditional religion like
christianity
or it's going to be a modern religion
like secular leftism
same thing here you're you're going to
indoctrinate students one way or the
other
because indoctrinate comes from the word
doctor it just means to teach so what
are you going to teach them are you
going to teach them the classics
you're going to teach them reading
writing and arithmetic are you going to
teach them the things that they need
to be free people like the liberal arts
or are you going to teach them a bunch
of creepy
sex ideology and are you going to teach
them a bunch of racial grievance
and are you going to teach them to
become part of the liberal revolution
this has real effects there was a video
that was going around the internet
yesterday
that was it was shocking
in its audacity you know we've seen a
lot of videos coming out
from the riots the peaceful riots you
know where people are are for social
justice stealing a pair of nikes
and one thing about those videos is
usually onlookers right
and sometimes their onlookers will say
hey what are you doing why are you
stealing those sneakers what
i was stealing from gucci gonna stop
police brutality
what made this woman's video a little
different is that she was live streaming
it
herself she was live streaming herself
committing a crime and looting all i kid
you not
in the name of social justice take a
listen
how you get out of them they own this
thing right here
look they tried to pull it out but they
ain't coming out
i don't know what i'm so she's she's
that's all she's trying to get the keys
to take the tags off of the clothing
that she's stealing
hold on let me see did they say
valentino
that's a good thing for valentine's she
got good taste i guess let me find me
some first time hold on
you can hear other people kind of
yelling running around this door
there it is i can't breathe she says
i can't breathe quoting what george
floyd said
which kicked off all of these riots
allegedly
now that that picture is complicated
because what this woman seems to be
suggesting
is george floyd said i can't breathe
because uh derek siobhan the officer had
his knee on george floyd's neck but we
saw from the full body cam footage is
george floyd had been yelling i can't
breathe
much earlier just when he was standing
around and refusing a rest
but that's what we're being told i can't
breathe i can't breathe
if you're going to say that if you're
going to live stream yourself stealing
stuff from a department store
and laughing about it talking about how
you want some more valentino
what it means is you've imbibed a bs
historical narrative
in the modern history meaning that
there's this scourge of racist cops
going around hunting innocent black
people around the country
that is not happening there is zero zero
evidence that that is happening
but a lot of people believe that it
means you've imbibed a bs historical
narrative
that black people have no ability to
succeed in america there's been no
improvement we're basically
living in the old terrible slavery days
and the founders were racists and they
didn't believe all men are created equal
and they just they just launched the
revolution in fact they just launched it
to protect slavery
that lie that the 1619 project out of
the new york times says
even though even left-wing historians
admit that's bs means you've you've
imbibed that fake historical narrative
the other thing it means
is you're a criminal with no sense of
shame because even if you feel like
you've been wronged
the sort of traditional good virtuous
understanding of that is i've been
wronged
and i will suffer and that suffering
will be sanctifying and i'm not going to
livestream myself stealing a bunch of
gucci shoes there's nothing honorable or
noble about that
and laughing and yelling and taking
other people's property but if you have
no education don't forget education
isn't just
facts that go in your head it's not just
learning how to do
basic arithmetic and learning about
history which is one damn fact after
another
education is about the whole person it's
it's how you behave it's how you're
raised
he wasn't raised right he was raised
right it's having good manners
i mean if you just think even in the
latin languages the word
educate also means like your behavior
means you
obviously were not raised right and then
the third thing and this is the
essential one for our political
situation if you're if you're filming
yourself doing that
it means you have no fear of punishment
zero fear
you're flaunting it in people's faces
think about this if if a regular old
vandal wants to go in and mess up some
property or maybe
maybe steal something from a store he
does it surreptitiously he hides it
he conceals it right he doesn't want to
get caught because there are
consequences
now we see the left encouraging this
kind of thing
and this woman imbibing that realizes
she's not going to get in trouble so she
just
she just steals outright
all of that is based on poor education
you can blame a lot of other factors too
and bad politicians and
yada yada yada but it boils down to bad
education what are we going to do about
that
bad education doesn't just happen on the
extreme
activist side you know of the of the
people on the front lines and the left
doesn't just have to do with black lives
matter or anything else
it pervades the entire liberal
establishment there's this guy
john fuchel saying you know john jenn
fuglesang was an actor and i think now
he hosts a serious radio tv show
s-i-r-i-u-s not s-e-o is it not serious
it's on serious and uh he and i have
kind of sparred every now and again at
some
events politicon john fuglesang
said one of the dumbest things i've ever
heard
and he has a habit of doing this
particularly on the topic of
christianity
but he got caught doing it yesterday and
it shows you kind of the the circular
firing ring squad of the left
john fugal saying tweet he's kind of
known for tweeting out bad bible takes
he just his whole his whole shtick is
shaming people
for being christian and supporting
republican candidates
and he has this he has this theory that
the bible supports abortion
which obviously it does not and he
regularly exhibits his ignorance on this
topic but
but that's the whole shtick it's not it
doesn't really have anything to do with
the bible he
he just wants to make a mockery of
conservative christians
and the his followers who know even less
about the bible than he does
go along with this so he tweets out
yesterday he goes the only white people
in the bible
are the ones who executed jesus
zing you got him uh but as you might
imagine this
attracted a lot of controversy because
it sounds kind of anti-semitic doesn't
it you know we we know that the
jewish high priests the sanhedrin were
the ones who
came over and were trying trying to get
jesus you know trying to get him and
then they
delivered him up to the romans and the
romans eventually executed him
but for a lot of people both on the on
the left
and uh and on the right uh they they
took this to be an anti-semitic remark
and john fugal sang followed up he said
i'm sorry i'm sorry
i honestly thought everyone would
understand this to be the romans i
underestimated how many people still
blame the jews
which is how the romans wanted it so
he's like no no i would never
exhibit ignorant bigotry against jews i
meant to exhibit ignorant bigotry
against italians but
it actually does come down from biblical
illiteracy and historical illiteracy
he then came after the daily wire for
some reason i don't know why he said
since the revoltingly fake christians of
the daily wire are using this quote
for angry right-wing white guy crack
white guy's terrible by the way white
there are worse people on earth every
other person
is way better because of their race and
sex but white guy's horrible it's worth
pointing out that anti-semites have
always
blamed exclusively the jews for jesus's
execution
i mention this tweet because there's
this funny thing that the left does
which is the left will say and you'll
notice it sometimes they do this often
they'll say christianity is terrible
it's stupid
it's foolish it's the cause of
of the greatest evil in the world it led
to
colonialism and this ism and that ism
and also you guys are a bunch of fake
christians
if if christianity is as bad as you say
isn't it
isn't it better to be a fake christian
than a real christian
they try to hit you for both things at
once this is something that has been
a consistent attack on the church from
the very beginning it's
one of the great arguments for why the
church is the church is they they'll hit
you for both sides they'll say
the church is too ascetic and they'll
say the church is too luxurious right or
they'll
they'll kind of hit you from both angles
and so this one says christianity is so
terrible and also
it'd be so much better if you were a
real christian not a fake christian
and uh then he follows it up and he says
just remember it's not
possible to follow both trump and jesus
anyone who says you can has read neither
of their books but
america is where the right-wing got
christians to vote against all the
actual teachings of christ
by screaming about abortion which christ
doesn't mention of course christ
does mention that he makes it quite
clear it's it's wrong to murder babies
but that's neither here nor there what
it shows you is a couple things one
it shows you that there is this
alternate religion of the left
right the le we know that religion is
fundamental to people so they've got to
set up kind of their own separate
religion
that is a contender against christianity
but it shows you
the role of ignorance anybody who's ever
cracked open the spine of a bible knows
that this guy is completely full of it
but how many people have cracked open
the spine of a bible how many people
even
you're not even allowed to read the
bible in schools it's the it's the
essential book of western civilization
you can read a bunch of stupid
post-modern novels but you can't read
the bible
that's the problem it didn't happen by
accident this is part
of a wider plan we'll get into that plan
first though i've got to thank our
friends over at rock auto you know how
much i love rock auto
speaking of ignorance i will confess to
some ignorance i don't know that much
about cars
that's why it's very easy when something
goes wrong in my car for
unscrupulous car part salesmen
to uh to pull one over on me you know
you go into the brick and mortar store
you say i don't get this problem with my
car
and they'll say okay yeah well yeah we
don't have the part in stock but we
gotta go online they go online they
probably go to rockauto.com
and then they just charge you twice as
much well don't do that you don't need
to do that rockauto.com makes it so easy
their website is so simple intuitive
easy to navigate that even i can do it
which is pretty shocking they've also
they've been a family business serving
online auto parts customers
for 20 years that's about as long as
online has existed they've been in
they always offer reliably low prices
and the prices are the same for the
professionals and the do-it-yourselfers
why spend up to twice as much for the
same parts head on over
to rockauto.com right now you can see
all the parts available for your car or
truck and then most importantly
write nulls canon wles in their how did
you hear about us box
so that they know that we sent you that
is rockauto.com
the left perverts history the left
perverts religion
and then where do these intersect the
left perverts science we were talking
about this a little bit
i think last week how very
very directly especially from the
progressive era onward
one way that the left has gained control
and the progressives have gained control
is they've they've changed science and
history and so science now is a capital
s
and a trademark over the e and it's
always settled and it's always whatever
they say
and they're you know they've also then
applied that to history and they say
there's a science of history
once you know the science of history you
know how history is going to end you
know if you're on the right or the wrong
side of history
there's a science to politics we're no
longer debating the eternal questions
about justice and equality and liberty
nope sorry you don't get any control
over that anymore we're going to
outsource your whole your politics to
the scientists and the white lab coats
they're going to run our lives for us
it'll be totally fine we're going to
have the social sciences
they're going to tell you how to spend
your money how to live what sort of
social relations to be and it's all just
science science science
science of course it's not really
science
in the in the classical sense of that
term it's just whatever they want
in their political views while they tell
you to shut up
sometimes they tell you to
be even more intimidated than just
shutting up sometimes they threaten
to murder you which is what a nashville
city council member just did sharon hurt
who is an at-large member of the
nashville metro council says
that if you don't wear the mask you know
wear the damn mask if you don't wear the
mask
you should be tried for murder
if mike jameson could be the one to
answer the question but my concern
is you know i work for an organization
that if they pass a virus
then they are tried for
murder or attempted murder if they are
not
told and this person
who may very well pass this
virus that's out in the air because
they're not wearing a mask
is basically doing the same thing to
someone who
contracts it and dies from it
makes perfect sense right if you
we know from science if you don't wear
the mask
then you are spreading the virus because
the mask is not to protect
you i know early on they said it was to
protect you but then they changed their
minds the mask is to protect everyone
else
and i know the masks you know they're
not that effective but but
but now maybe they are effective and i
know early on they told you don't wear
them please do not wear them now they're
telling you you have to wear them
but regardless now where we are because
of science we know
with 100 certainty that you are
murdering people
if you don't wear the mask even though
the virus has what 99.7
survival rates something like that at
least
very very very high 90s right even at
the most dire dire views of it
still you're murdering people is that
right is that how it works now the
science
the real science doesn't show that at
all actually
the real science shows what i have been
saying for many months now
which is the masks are extremely dumb
and worse than being dumb they are a
political symbol that is being used
to shape and control the way that
politically we think about this thing
new study published in science advances
was was testing how the masks
affect the droplet transmission rate so
you know the masks aren't
controlling all the way that the virus
could be transmitted but we're talking
about droplets
you know when you speak if you speak
like a shakespearean actor
if you're very plosive on your p's
sometimes a little bit of spittle comes
out little droplets
and so the argument for the masks is
well it doesn't stop everything but it
does stop some of these little droplets
okay well does it
how what what is the effect of the masks
on the droplets well it turns out
that you know if you could
if you had a 90 transmission rate with
the mask that means that it's reducing
it by 10
right or 50 it's reducing the droplet
transmission by
50 percent or if it were 10 rats
reducing it by 90
so for uh some of these masks how does
it how does it work out
for the uh neck
gaiter mask that's the one where people
can wear it around their neck and then
they just pull it up over their nose
the droplet transmission is 110
it's 10 higher higher than not wearing a
mask
it transmits the virus more aggressively
than if you just didn't wear the stupid
mask
how about face shields you have i don't
know if you've noticed if you go to
dinner at all depending on what city
you're in
some sometimes you'll see the servers
wearing face shields like they're
they're boba fett in star wars or like
there's some kind of
space creature so they'll put the
shields on maybe like they're welding or
something
and you say i don't think that those
shields are doing anything now well
according to the cdc
we're all right cdc does not recommend
using
these face shields because they don't
actually stop the spread of anything
how about all the how about the most
popular mask probably the other than
those blue ones which we already know
don't do very much
the masks that came out right away there
they go across your whole face and they
have a little vent in here so that
you're not totally suffocating yourself
what about those well according to the
cdc
they don't do anything at all if your
mask has an exhalation valve or vent
they don't do anything at all we don't
know if they may increase transmission
we just don't know
they certainly don't help it that's the
science i'm sure the science is going to
change again
in the next couple of days but in the
meantime pay attention to what's really
going on because i don't think that
anybody
is going to react to those studies by
saying okay i guess we don't need to
worry about the masks so much
no they're going to double down because
that's been the point from the beginning
because as was true of the progressives
100 years ago is true today this is not
about science at all
this is about politics and what the left
is doing
is weaponizing ignorance the most
egregious example of this
went all the way to new york you
remember andrew cuomo in new york he's
he's being hailed as the great
leader on coronavirus even though he
handled it worse than any governor in
the country
his state then got hit worse than any
governor in the country he then took a
bunch of sick people and sent them into
nursing homes
which house the only group that is
seriously susceptible to coronavirus
and thousands and thousands of senior
citizens died because of his
stupid policies well this might prompt
people to say hmm
maybe we should investigate what
happened with those policies how those
policies came to be
why they led to the death of thousands
of senior citizens andrew cuomo
he doesn't think that's such a good idea
you know so much for free inquiry so
much for the advance of the sciences
for the advance of the academy now
andrew cuomo wants to put a lid on that
we'll get into that in one second and
then we'll get into the final
political point of it all the left now
more openly than ever
is trying to steal this election we'll
get into how they're doing it first
though
got to thank our friends over at liquid
iv you know some people are athletes
and so they sweat a lot because they go
running or playing football
i don't know what they do some of us
though we prefer to maybe we stay out a
little bit late maybe we have a couple
of uh adult beverages with our friends
either way you got to stay hydrated you
got to stay hydrated just generally just
in your regular day-to-day life
people don't get enough water okay well
liquid iv is the wonderful popular
hydration drink mix they've launched
their newest line energy
multiplier with roughly 100 milligrams
of clean caffeine it is the perfect
coffee replacement and an all-natural
alternative to processed energy drinks
for a sustained energy boost throughout
the day
half of americans report that they
struggle not just with dehydration but
with daily fatigue
some signs of that include decreased
focus lack of motivation
poor mood unhappiness with liquid iv
energy multiplier you can take
your day to the next level the boost
you'd get from one or two cups of coffee
without the crash contains a mixture of
matcha
guayuza and ginger that is high in
antioxidants that helps to improve mood
and focus and it's a healthy alternative
to traditional energy drinks
and coffee no artificial flavors or
preservatives i really love these guys
liquid iv totally works it's available
nationwide at costco or you can get 25
off when you go to liquidive.com and use
code michael
at checkout 25 off anything you order
when you use promo code michael at
liquidity.com start fueling your
adventures today at liquidity.com
promo code michael andrew cuomo does not
like the idea
of an investigation into what happened
at these nursing homes a reporter asked
him
state lawmakers today are investigating
covet 19 in nursing homes there was some
criticism for the state health
commissioner for not appearing before
the panel so the state health
commissioner
totally stolen stonewalling them as well
would you support an independent
investigation in order to bridge some of
this mutual suspicion
about partisanship getting into a better
public understanding of what happened
in these home facilities and group home
facilities and nursing homes
and cuomo we can't find the video so
i'll just have to do my cuomo impression
try to try to imagine i look like a
bulldog
no i wouldn't do an investigation
whether or not it's political
everybody can make that decision for
themselves
i think you'd have to be blind to
realize it's not political
nothing to see here folks nothing to see
here now
obviously he's just trying to turn
people away from his own
egregious failures bloody bloody
failures on this issue
but what he said here is something that
that actually gets to the heart of how
the left perverts education
he says no i don't want an investigation
i don't want people to look at the facts
i think everybody can make that decision
for themselves we so often hear this in
education here
kids shouldn't have content-based
learning they should learn to come to
conclusions for themselves
but you can't you can't come to
conclusions in education
unless you learn stuff i remember this
was true even when i was going through
school
you would always hear look you don't
need to learn facts just learn broad
themes just long broad patterns
but you might realize you can't learn a
pattern
unless you know the individual parts
that make up the pattern
you need to know the individual dots
before you can figure out what connects
them
but what the left says is no no don't
learn the facts
they say oh who needs the fact you have
google you don't need facts
you have the internet you don't need
facts just learn that well what is the
pattern what is the theme
it is the narrative that they want to
impose
on history on culture on religion on
whatever
that's the lie i mean what cuomo is
saying here he's using a trick
that is tried and true it's 100 years
old at least
cover up the particulars don't let
people form their own conclusions he's
saying let them form their own
conclusions and he's taking away the
only mechanism they would have
to do such a thing speaking of
conclusions
we're in an election year we're all
debating over how and when people are
going to vote
but what about the conclusion on
election night are we going to get it
unfortunately
our election commissioner says probably
not we'll get to that
we'll get to some people finally waking
up at a walk away rally
in beverly hills we'll get to so much
more but first i got to thank you i got
to thank you for heading on over
to the michael knowles show youtube
channel i'm glad that you go to the
daily wire youtube channel
it's fine to give ben the clicks better
however to go to the michael knowles
show one
uh we've got a great interview with eric
taxis up there we got exclusive videos
like the best
and of the worst tick tock so that you
will know exactly why trump
promptly banned and deleted it also all
access that's our exclusive membership
tier
uh the all access membership tier is
great we we form friendships you know
we're able to
talk to people in the all access show
right now you'll get not one but two
leftist tiers tumblers with your
membership you'll also get exclusive
access to some products that will only
be available to all access we just had a
baseball bat with the daily wire logo it
blaze and don it
there's a limited run it sold out only
to all access sold out in 48 hours i was
not even able to get one which is very
frustrating
but head on over right now you go to
dailywire.com you'll get 20
off all access with coupon code access
dailywire.com
knowles coupon code access to get 25 20
rather not 25 don't get greedy 20
off your membership will be back with a
lot more
we're in this election i hope it's an
election i hope it's free and fair
that's our tradition in america but this
might not be you know the left hates
transparency
you heard it right at the top that
public school teacher says
no we don't know now with online
learning parents might learn what we're
teaching their kids
we can't have any of that andrew cuomo
says no we can't have any investigation
into why my policies led to thousands of
senior citizens dying
and now we're not getting transparency
on
our election this is why the left loves
mail-in voting when you've got an
election day and a ballot location then
you get a lot of election watchers and
they show up for ballot security to make
sure
democrats don't pull the kind of tricks
that they've been pulling for a very
long time
mail-in voting you don't get that it's
any day you send it in maybe it gets
lost in the mail
there we played an experiment on this
show uh just last week where
some three percent of ballots got lost
in the mail when a news organization
tried it
the left loves this but even if mail-in
ballots
work perfectly people still aren't going
to post market
by the date that they have to post
market before they're not going to post
market two weeks before the election
so what that means is if 100 million
people vote by mail-in ballot
there's a very good chance that on
election night we're not going to have
any idea who won
let me just tell everybody we're all
going to need to take a deep breath
and be patient this year because you
know the
the there's a substantial chance we are
not going to know
on election night what the results are
for
possibly for the presidency but maybe
for many other
races that are important to people and
that's okay if it takes a little bit
longer to count
all the votes accurately that's what we
need to do
in order to ensure that everyone's vote
counts
that's federal election commissioner
ellen weintraub
and it is not okay it's not okay that
we're not going to find out
who the winner is on election night it's
not okay that there
will be permitted now lots of
shenanigans behind the scenes it's not
okay
that people are not going to show up to
the polling station where we can watch
with transparency these kind of
elections it's not okay
that you you don't have to even show an
id to show that you're even eligible to
vote
it's not okay it is a con
it is a scam it is an attempt to steal
our election
by corrupt democrats that's what it is
plain and simple
and unfortunately some republicans
haven't pushed back enough against
the mail in voting why can't they push
back enough hard enough look there's
always been some mail in voting absentee
or maybe you're traveling but in that
limited number it doesn't swing
elections it's not as
rife for abuse even though it does get
abused
why can't republicans push back against
the widespread national mail-in ballots
because we haven't pushed back hard
enough against the lockdowns
why haven't we pushed down hard enough
against the lockdowns because we haven't
pushed back hard enough against the bs
science narrative that changes its mind
every five seconds on the virus and
doesn't even admit of new facts
it's in these early small things that
you see the rot
and republicans conservatives we don't
get that we only want to fight on the
big issues
we don't realize how the seeds of this
destruction are planted very early
you can see that obviously in the last
five six months for the coronavirus
but you can also see that with our
education system
we all want to fight the political
battles we all want to fight at the
battle box we all want to donate to
campaigns
we might even donate to some
organizations that try to convince
people of things you know activist
organizations
we don't realize though that whole
generations have
already been formed by the time we talk
to them they're already formed in
kindergarten first grade second grade
pre-k fifth grade they go all the way up
to 12th grade
then they'll go through college they've
already been formed
that's where the battle has to begin
otherwise we get to the point where when
we start trying to talk to people
once they've graduated college or in
college it's too late we want to start
fighting this voter fraud now
it's too late we've already lost that
now some people the one consolation here
we sometimes talk about the conservative
consolation is that reality reasserts
itself
in the end well reality is for some
people reasserting itself there was a
walk away rally in beverly hills
walk away rallies the whole walkway
movement is this idea that the various
identity groups
that have been divvied up by the left
are kind of waking up to the con and
saying wait a second
the left the democrats don't really
support my interests so they're going to
walk away and they're going to vote for
republicans so
there was some woke white liberal guy
who was scolding some black woman about
how it's against her
racial or gender interests to vote for
republicans
and this woman i don't know her name but
she let him have it
my life matters i don't need your
privilege to tell me
or to justify who i am in america this
is my
[Applause]
so i'm going to walk country here as
bold as i want to
and i don't have to have you name it
right there your voice is
but you are supporting an organization
that does not like
black men and as a black woman i can
tell you how important black
men are to the black family without them
we are nothing
so when you support an organization that
doesn't push them up
the way we need them to be you ain't
[ __ ] from
love her totally love her want her to
run for mayor of la or beverly hills or
whatever
she gets it right down to the bottom so
this
this white liberal kid is talking about
how great black lives matter is because
you don't know anything about black
lives or black lives matter for that
matter black lives matter is terrible
for black people
black lives matter is terrible for a
great many reasons but
in particular because it wants to
subvert the family
it's very bad for black men and
if you're supporting the destruction of
the black family then you're
as bad as anybody you're totally
destroying black lives
she gets two things here that
the the left is relying on to divvy up
the country and gain more power one is
the left wants diversity so they push
this
ridiculous line diversity is our
strength and what they mean by diversity
is
truly division they want people to feel
totally separated
diversity in that sense is not our
strength unity is our strength
there's an older idea in america called
a pluribus unum
out of many one that we all come
together there's the idea of the melting
pot which developed in the 20th century
the idea that we all come together from
maybe from different places but we all
melt together into an american culture
we are
united we because we maybe we don't look
the same maybe we don't do exactly the
same things
but we do have an american unity we've
got to come together that's the only
way to fight leftist politics some
conservatives maybe they're well-meaning
but certainly they're naive
they think we can beat the left on
identity politics grounds
they think that we'll be able to claim
identity group loyalty to us so so they
do it they do it often with black people
they'll say
democrats say that black people must
vote for democrats but we say black
people must vote for republicans
or they'll say gay people democrats
aren't representing your interests we
are vote for us gay people
it's actually missing the point the
point is
we are americans we're all americans you
should vote for the party that supports
america
not the party that burns the american
flag and tears down statues of george
washington
but we are all americans this woman says
it she goes this is my country
oh democrats they get so angry they get
furious
when their pet identity politics groups
acknowledge that america is their
country feel loyalty and gratitude
for america they don't like that but
it's true
this is our country all together you
should vote for the party that supports
the country
not the party that wants to tear the
country down and then what she realizes
is the importance of institutions not
just starting at the level of the
federal government
not just the state not just the
municipal government not even just the
voluntary associations
the family the family the building block
of society
the only thing between you and the
tyrannical government the family
it's not some people think that the
basic building block of society is the
atomized individual
some people think it's the collective
overall
those are two sides of the same coin the
left can only
gather you up into one collective once
they've split you up from all of your
institutions most importantly the family
into atomized individuals that's what
how communism operates that's how
fascism operates
fascism literally comes from the
description of the bundle of sticks
that they're all separate and then
they're bounded together in the state
the family is what will protect you this
woman gets it
we should all get it too some people
realize
in our government even though the
activists i understand
regular old people they get it much
better than most politicians
but there are some politicians who
understand what's going on too attorney
general bill barr
the honey badger as senator cruz once
dubbed him on our show verdict
bill barr was driving by in a car and
saw a bunch of pro cop protesters
he tells the driver turn around gets out
of the car start shaking everybody's
hand
there is there waving american flags
signs that say back the blue
keep up the good work attorney general
you're so happy to see him they don't
hate him they're not throwing
frozen water bottles or monotone
cocktails
just good americans thanking another
good american
waving the american flag these days it
does your heart
good that is a great image
you know yesterday we played that that
mayor of portland
who who was yelling at ted wheeler he
was he was yelling at the protesters
because he said
you're giving the trump campaign b-roll
footage for their campaign ads
b-roll footage right he's saying no
your the trump campaign is now going to
exploit what you are doing he's just
going to show people what you're doing
and that's going to help him win
elections well that sort of thing does
help because
no matter how how much people have been
indoctrinated perverted in this idea of
how to think about their country how to
think about their history how to think
about religion how to think about our
relationship to one another
we can still see reality right you see
these images still crop up in the end
and when you look at a country that is
on fire
literally on fire where everything we've
cherished is being torn down
and then you look at a country of nice
smiling people waving the american flag
thanking everyone
coming together you look at a country of
a woman saying i want to i want my
family
i want my country that is much more
appealing that appeals to us on a base
level we no longer know why that's
appealing
because the left has weaponized
ignorance for 100 years
but it does it is still appealing and it
is incumbent on us by the way
not just to leave it at that sentimental
feeling not even just to go out and vote
for politicians who
encourage that sentimental feeling we
must educate ourselves it's amazing how
people
who even if they think they got some
elite education they probably didn't
they probably haven't read the federal
list you know the reason right now that
i'm in
i'm not in the studio i'm i'm down
further down in southern california is
because i'm participating in the
claremont fellowship the lincoln
fellowship
to go back to our founding documents to
go back through the history of our
country
figure out what happened figure out what
it means figure out what has been
covered up a lot of this stuff
would have been basic education 50 years
ago
but now not even people who go to
fantasy schools get this kind of thing
it's frankly especially people who go to
fancy schools don't get this kind of
education
it is incumbent on us because what the
left is relying on
is a sort of weaponized ignorance
and some people some i'll leave you on
this note some people
can school the left uh even at the
political level we're talking about ted
wheeler who's upset about the
the riots in portland being used in
trump campaign ads kaylee mcinning he
called him out for it
for the our national heartthrob kaylee
mcenany from the white house press
briefing take a listen
finally one thing i want to leave you
guys with is that 18 days ago
mayor ted wheeler tweeted what i saw
last night
in portland was powerful in many ways i
listened heard and stood with protesters
and i saw what it means when the federal
government
unleashes paramilitary forces against
its own people
he in fact called our federal agents
paramilitary forces
and around this same time our federal
officers were facing
rioters barricading officers inside the
courthouse trapping officers inside
launching of commercial grade fireworks
a federal agent's hand was impaled by
planted nails
three officers were likely were at least
temporarily i should say
um blinded when a laser was put in their
eyes this has been an ongoing tactic by
the rioters
that was 18 days ago when mayor wheeler
stood with the rioters
and against the quote paramilitary
forces
but just four days ago it appears mayor
wheeler had a change of heart
it took him 73 days i i suppose to come
up with that realization
took him a long time it was only once
those videos went viral once people saw
what was really happening that wheeler
started to push back a little bit
he thought the violence would help him
politically it would intimidate people
it would it would force people into
allowing the left to run roughshod over
their cities
but then people started to see it that's
the key here we are never going to match
the left on passion and emotion
and insults and screaming and hysteria
we're not going to
we're outmatched okay they are the
varsity athletes of that they are
olympians
at shrieking and hysteria but where we
can beat them where we must beat them
is showing people what's really
happening right now what really happened
in 1776 what happened before that what
happened
all the way in between the the way we
will fight back is giving people
the facts and i think when the facts are
out on the table
we're gonna we're gonna look very good
not just in november but we'll have a
real shot in the future that's our show
i'm michael knowles it's the michael
knowles show
see you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies
executive producer jeremy boary
supervising producers
mathis glover and robert sterling
technical producer austin stevens
assistant director pavel wadowski editor
and associate producer
danny d'amico audio mixer robin
fenderson
hair and makeup nika geneva production
assistant
ryan love the michael knowles show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire
20 20. if you prefer facts over feelings
aren't offended by the brutal truth and
you can still laugh at the insanity
filling our national news cycle we'll
tune in to the ben shapiro show we'll
get a whole lot of that and much more
see you there